and CBS News confirms the Vatican has
secret guidelines for priests who father
children despite their vows of celibacy
Vincent Doyle the founder of a support
group for children of priests told us a
Vatican official showed him the
confidential instructions during the
church to publicly support those
children who often grow up living in
shame and secrecy Roxana Saberi spoke
with him and other children of priests
fighting for recognition from the church
for nearly nine centuries the Catholic
Church has forbidden its clergymen from
sex and marriage but Sarah Thomas says
she's proof that priests sometimes break
their vows my mother had been told to
keep it a secret by the church
Thomas was 14 when she first met her
father a priest in England it seemed
became apparent that he couldn't or
wouldn't and wasn't allowed to be any
sort of father to me what was the
hardest part about all of this growing
up feeling very isolated I literally
thought I was the only priest child in
the world but she now believes there
could be thousands of children like her
and they're slowly being recognized
starting in Ireland in 2017 the
country's Catholic Church published
groundbreaking guidelines for priests
declaring if a priest father's a child
the well-being of his child should be
his first consideration and he should
face up to his responsibilities personal
legal moral and financial special to me
because my father spent time here
Vincent Doyle pushed for the guidelines
after learning that is late Godfather an
Irish priest was his real father the
guidelines were the first time the
Catholic Church have admitted that there
are priests kids but these are
guidelines they're not requirements no
but the first problem with children of
priests is they're not recognized why is
recognition so important well when
you're hidden you are characterized by
secrecy
what does secrecy do to a child
it eats away at their sense of worth
more than a year since the Catholic
Church here in Ireland approved the
guidelines for priests with children
church officials around the world are
taking notice the Catholic Church in
America is looking at a similar model
and the Vatican says the issue is on its
agenda Doyle has pressed Pope Francis to
announce similar guidelines for all
clergymen it's taken time for the
Vatican to respond what do you want from
the Pope
these children are recognized we
acknowledge your pain we condemn this
pain I may want to fix this pain to help
them with their pain dole created the
website coping international offering
resources and counseling there's a
worldwide community people growing
Thomas is part of that community and is
doing a PhD on it being taken what's
coming out more and more is that these
children are ready for some change that
change is very difficult for the
Catholic Church but change is happening
they will no longer suffer she says in
silence for CBS this morning Roxana
Saberi knock Ireland
it's a silence that gets you every time
I can't imagine what it would be like
not to be acknowledged for who you are
and where you came you know we talked
about this a lot abuse fosters in
silence circlin how to open the doors to
this acknowledging it they were opening
the doors